governors in hard-hit states warned that
they are facing ventilator shortages as
they confront may what may be the peak
of this pandemic in states like New York
Louisiana and Michigan doctors may soon
face life-and-death decisions about who
will get a breathing machine and who
will not our dr. Tara Narula shows us
how hospitals all across the country are
tackling the crisis my father was larger
than life
Jade Roth's father former theater
director Jerry Roth lived according to
his own script but in the end his
daughter says coronavirus robbed 78 year
old Roth of his final chapter he died of
heart failure just days after his New
York City Hospital canceled his elective
heart surgery when he was told the
procedure was cancelled you felt like it
precipitated some of his very quick
decline yes I did now that clearly is a
subjective view and I want to be very
clear that there are always hard
decisions to be made and I don't see
that there's any blame here still Jade
Roth wonders what makes one life more
worth saving than another a question
Indianapolis dr. Joseph Smith hopes he
never has to answer as a physician it's
it's nauseating in just the mere idea
that we would take a step back and say
that one person is more likely to
survive than the other so we should
provide the intensive care to the person
that's more likely to survive that is a
very difficult thing with Hospital
visitations limited New York
cardiologist Evelina graver shows us how
many conversations are happening
this is graver helping her 84 year old
patient FaceTime with his daughter for
the first time since he was intubated
just days earlier in this video diary to
tell them the fact that we no longer can
provide
the critical carrot that your family
member need
graver grapples with the new ethical
questions she's facing I'm not God I'm
far from God
I'm just very limited limited in
resources how many people heard dr.
Stephen Thomas thinks physicians should
not have to shoulder the burden of
deciding who gets resources and who
doesn't so he helped build a triage team
at SUNY Upstate Medical University to
create a blueprint its administrators
like chief medical officers for example
critical care physicians effects
diseases ethicists spiritual leaders
they're basically getting together to
try and understand you know what is the
objective evidence that we have that
will allow us to sort of prognosticate
who does or does not have a high
likelihood of surviving and trying to
basically just come up with in a fair
and transparent way
that everyone can agree upon
bioethicists Scott Halpern helped write
the guidelines that are being used in
most Pennsylvania hospitals to decide
how to fairly allocate things like
ventilators and ICU beds everyone gets
assigned a priority from one through
eight where one is the highest priority
and then we let the supply on a given
day determine how many people get those
resources is age a factor at all in how
you prioritize people age is only a
factor as a last resort tiebreaker and
no other personals characteristic be it
race gender disability or anything else
goes into the calculus at all if there
was a hospital that did not have this in
place it may fall on the treating doctor
to be making some of these decisions
what kind of impact might that have on
that physician I think it would be hard
to overstate the potential stress that
this decision-making really requires if
it falls to you at the bedside because
it is an impossible choice yeah it is a
truly impossible choice
and dr. taryn Narula joins us now
dr. Narula good morning it sounds like
it's very clear from your piece that
there are no longer good choices at
these hospitals only hard choices and
one of those choices that were
reportedly that's reportedly popping up
are do not resuscitate orders Universal
do not resuscitate orders for
coronavirus patients in some hospitals
what can you tell us about those well
this is a concept that's very difficult
for us to wrap our mind around and many
people think it is a little bit trakone
Ian but really it signifies this shift
from looking at the well-being of the
patient in front of us to the well-being
of the population at large this is not a
typical way that we're used to thinking
essentially what it means is if you come
into an emergency room and you are coded
positive universally the decision would
be made that you are a DNR
do-not-resuscitate you would not be
resuscitated if you went into cardiac
arrest with CPR now the reason behind
this is that when you perform CPR you
aerosolize a lot of droplets it's a very
it becomes a very infectious and high
risk for those treating the patient the
reality is that it's it's very unlikely
that people tend to survive cardiac
arrest when they're in the hospital
survival rates around 20% and requires a
lot of personal protective equipment so
that's why that is being floated around
now
the bigger issue really is that families
should be having a discussion about DNR
and code status and living wills and
health care proxies now before they ever
get into a situation when they're in the
hospital it's a tough conversation but
it needs to be happening at home with
families yeah you've got to think about
these things before it's a hand because
in the moment the the crisis just
engulfs you you mentioned guidelines at
a Pennsylvania Hospital you know who
gets the preferential treatment beyond
the people you mentioned in the piece
right so it's important to note that
there is no set of uniform standardized
guidelines in this country and the Penn
guidelines really are looking at two
things what is the chances that somebody
will survive to get out of the hospital
and what are the chances that they will
have a long term lifespan survivability
and then outside of that they're
assigned that point score if they need a
tiebreaker
let's say you and I have the same score
Tony they would look at age and they
would look at who is a health care
provider who is contributing to treating
this epidemic or pandemic and that
person would get higher priority
important to note that all patients get
treated the same with this scoring
system it's amazing dr. Narula all the
experts in the world can can run through
those calculations but I don't know that
they'll ever make sense to families who
don't get the treatment for their loved
one very hard choices here dr. nurullah
thank you very much